[Music]
foreign
earlier this week we discussed our
pathetic impotent criminal justice
system which has utterly failed to
maintain Law and Order in our
communities it's a justice system that
seems to be uninterested in Justice and
I proposed as you recall that we take
off the kid gloves and start dealing
harshly with criminals Predators those
who've turned our cities into wreaking
zombified wastelands in fact I advocated
that we adopt some of Singapore some of
Singapore strategies in this regard
strategies that have helped to make
Singapore one of the safest and cleanest
places in the world while our cities
look like massive drug-infested garbage
dumps specifically I believe that we
like Singapore should adopt corporal
punishment for thieves and robbers and
vandals and the like and uh you know we
used to use corporal punishment on kids
in school now we've decided that it's
too mean to even use on multiply
convicted felons and I find that
attitude absurd and weak
the criminals also find our justice
system absurd and weak which is why they
have no respect for it and they have no
fear of breaking its laws and I also
believe that we like Singapore and like
Donald Trump has frequently suggested
for this country we ought to expand our
capital punishment regime to include
drug traffickers those who distribute
and sell Mass amounts of poison slowly
killing thousands of people every year
ought to face the ultimate penalty
nearly every murderer who has ever been
executed in the United States inflicted
less damage and killed fewer people than
the most prolific drug traffickers
there's no reason why drug traffickers
should get a more lenient sentence
indeed there's there's no reason why the
death penalty should be reserved only
for those who directly kill people
sometimes the most heinous kinds of
predators have other ways of preying
upon their fellow human beings child
rapists would be another example
with our ridiculous laws as they stand
in Most states you can't execute a child
rapist unless they're also guilty of
murder
as if the crime of child rape itself
doesn't warn it
I mean they deserve to die for their
crimes whether they directly kill their
victims or not
this is the case I made and I explained
my logic I think in extensive detail
still it has proven to be not
surprisingly controversial people on
both sides of the political divide are
deeply scandalized by my argument
Twitter has been basically unusable for
me over the past few days well it's
always basically unusable but especially
over the past few days because uh my
entire feed is just people screaming at
me for wanting to punish criminals
now look it's okay if you disagree with
me I I will I will give you permission
until my Theocratic fascist regime
officially begins anyway for now you do
have permission to disagree with me uh
you're wrong but but that's okay you can
be wrong
my problem is not that people simply
disagree with my proposal but that they
treat the mere notion of harsher
penalties for criminals has somehow
absurd on its face they recoil at the
suggestion that those who traffic
substances that kill thousands every
year should be given the same punishment
that we already give to other kinds of
murderers
they scream out in horror at the very
idea that perhaps we should sentence
robbers and thieves to corporal
punishment rather than letting them hang
out in prison for a few months and then
releasing them right back into the
community with no additional penalties
you know this is the issue
that you're not a stupid person for
listening to my argument finding it
unpersuasive and making a counter
argument I'm you know that doesn't that
that's that's fine
but you are frankly pretty damn stupid
if my argument is so shocking to you
that you can barely articulate a
response or if you think it's so
unthinkably extreme that it isn't
necessary to articulate a response
that kind of reaction to a perfectly
reasonable suggestion one with a massive
amount of historical precedent shows a
lack of thought on your part and an
ability inability to even entertain any
challenge to Modern orthodoxies because
that's really the problem right is that
what I'm saying flies in the face of our
kind of generally accepted Notions of
how to deal with criminals
and for that reason alone many people
are upset by it then they can't explain
really why it's just it just doesn't
comport with what they've always been
told and sort of the general atmosphere
that they live in
speaking of people who can barely
articulate a response that brings us to
YouTuber Kyle Kolinski who's the owner
of the secular talk Channel on YouTube
and um like most YouTubers on the left
every so often Kyle likes to use my name
to drive engagement and every so often I
will respond because well I I can't help
but take the bait So Yesterday Kyle put
out a video titled Matt Walsh's fascist
mask slips on Twitter
and he's part of the mob terribly upset
about my comments though he liked the
rest of them can't quite explain why
now most of Kyle's video consists of him
calling me stupid and authoritarian
while making incredulous facial
expressions
um not really a counter argument not
much to respond to but I did want to
address one part of it and it's this
part listen
Singapore is able to have nice things in
part because they execute drug dealers
by hanging
and arrest even Petty vandals and
thieves and beat them with a cane until
they bleed
we don't have nice things because we
aren't willing to do what is required to
maintain them
then he goes on to say
there are some accusing me of advocating
similar laws in this country and I just
want to clarify that yes absolutely I
want those laws in this country
okay
Matt Walsh is an authoritarian
and it's hilarious because the daily
wire Matt Walsh and others like to go
after the left and say oh the lifter
authoritarians and they hate Freedom bro
they hate Liberty bro
you hate Freedom you hate Liberty part
of freedom is being able to put in your
body whatever you want to put in your
body as long as you're not hurting
anybody else being able to sell said
substances in the same way I don't think
we should be hauling away the CEO of
Budweiser in handcuffs I don't think you
should haul away the weed dealer
he's saying
execute drug dealers
all right dog
you want to start go find the CEO of
Pfizer
and moderna
go find the guys who make Xanax
okay sounds good to me I mean we'd have
to give the big Pharma Executives a fair
trial of course convict them in a court
of law but once that's been done I
absolutely would want them to face the
same penalty that should be imposed on
any other drug trafficker see Kyle
you're not going to trip me up by
demanding that I take my arguments their
logical conclusions because I will
always do that I'm not afraid of doing
that that's the advantage to being
logically consistent okay so you go so
when you say well if that that's how you
feel then uh then that would lead to
this sure sounds good to me let's do
that too
it's an advantage of being logically
consistent that you yourself do not
enjoy because you have already made a
number of statements that I'm quite sure
you would not want to apply with total
consistency so you say that part of
freedom is not only being able to put
whatever you want into your body but
also being able to sell anything that
someone else might want to put in their
body
now here's the problem this argument
already assumes that freedom is itself
the highest good and therefore literally
anything that falls under the banner of
freedom is automatically good and and
should be permissible
but that's a case you need to make okay
you can't merely assume that
you haven't made it here or as far as I
know anywhere else
see I don't believe that freedom is the
highest good
I don't think that the ideal Society is
one where people are simply able to do
whatever they want all the time
I don't really think that I don't really
think that you think that either
actually I'm quite sure that there are
things that you would say people should
not be free to do
I'm quite sure of that
and yet your whole argument rests on
simply labeling drug trafficking part of
freedom
so already we have a number of logical
inconsistencies and sort of half-baked
ideas
let's talk about drug traffickers for a
moment now you um
keep making this this uh this you you
want to make this about weed first of
all and I I noticed that with all the
people that are arguing with me talk
about drug traffickers all they want to
do is talk about weed they bring it
right to eat I didn't specifically say
that I said drug traffickers
okay and you do that because you know
you'd sound ridiculous defending
fentanyl dealers on the basis of freedom
okay so you go for the for the easiest
form of the argument you can find
and you want to make this about
marijuana
but I'm not gonna let you off the hook
that easily so let's let's focus on
fentanyl dealers for a moment
they traffic and profit off of poison
just straight up poison that destroys
the lives of thousands of people and
kills thousands more and you say this is
okay because the people who use it want
to you know they want to use it so that
makes it okay
well why does their desire
to use the drug automatically make it
okay to sell it
is that the standard anything that
somebody might want to use is
automatically okay to sell
is that really is that really how you
think the law should work
and again your argument rests on an
assumption that you haven't actually
defended or explained
which is that freedom is the highest
good it's a good in and of itself and
anything that can be labeled Freedom
automatically should be allowed to
happen
besides even if the fentanyl user has
consented the entire rest of the
community plagued by the filth and crime
and violence the drug causes have not
consented okay the dealer might consent
the user might consent we'll get to that
in a second but the people forced to
live in communities utterly ravaged by
this poison do not consent to it
the people who are hopped up on these
drugs and then they run on to you know
run to a subway platform and throw an
old lady in front of the train she
didn't consent to that
she didn't consent to being part of this
she didn't consent to living in a city
that's The Walking Dead with drug
zombies walking around
oh and also by the way the user doesn't
consent either they're addicts they're
not making Clear Choices they are acting
out of desperation and compulsion and
addiction
the dealers and traffickers exploit that
for financial gain there's no Freedom
here Freedom has nothing to do with drug
addiction who the hell could look at a
heroin addict or a fentanyl addict or a
crackhead and say well that's Freedom
that is the opposite of freedom
so to review freedom is not a
self-explanatory defense of drug
trafficking it's also not a relevant
defense because one of the things that
makes drug trafficking so evil is that
the end user does not actually have
total freedom because they are enslaved
by the drug
but let's take addiction out of it let's
take drugs out of it okay let's let's
make this
even easier for you
you just said that people should be free
to sell
whatever anyone else wants to put in
their bodies
that's what you said
now I think that this is an utterly
ridiculous argument when it comes to
hard drugs but it's also ridiculous when
it comes to things that are not Drugs
That's How thoroughly ridiculous your
argument is so here's a thought
experiment just a thought experiment
Tide Pods you may remember a few years
ago when there was much consternation
over the tide pod challenge where an
idiots on Tick Tock or YouTube or
whatever would eat the laundry detergent
capsules and then get very sick and a
few cases would die now here's the
question what if the Tide detergent
company
decided that it wanted to lean into this
phenomenon so it began selling its
product as both a laundry detergent and
a snack
what if they put on their packaging Tide
Pods great for laundry great for
snacking and what if they even well
let's just say that they're being a
little bit more responsible they include
an FDA warning that though it can
physically be eaten it might be damaging
to your health
but still even with that warning they're
marketing it they are marketing it as a
consumable product remember you said
that people should be free to put
whatever they want to their bodies and
sellers should be free to sell whatever
anyone wants to put into their bodies
some people wanted to put Tide Pods in
their bodies why couldn't the tide
company therefore sell Tide Pods
specifically to that demographic put it
in a snack aisle next to the to the
potato chips
explicitly for the purpose of consuming
why couldn't they in other words
intentionally poison their customers
directly
what would be wrong with them sitting
around in a marketing room and saying
you know what some of our customers want
to be poisoned and killed by this let's
think of some ways to sell it to them
let's think of some ways to Market it
not just Market it to people who already
want to consume tripods but let's try to
convince people that they should eat
this stuff
and then sell it to them
the argument you made in defense of
fentanyl dealers would cover this tide
company hypothetical absolutely
now maybe you escaped this bind by
plunging forward and saying yeah sure a
tide should be able to legally Market
their product to those who want to eat
it
now that would make you consistent at
least but it would make you consistently
insane because you would be defending
the freedom of Corporations to
intentionally and directly poison their
customers
which would only go to show that freedom
in and of itself is not a valid defense
and of course you never did explain In
that clip or in any other part of your
diatribe what is so wrong with
non-lethal physical punishments of
criminals especially when even simply
putting someone in prison is a physical
punishment involving physical coercion
and force
should we abolish prisons too while
we're at it
and if we shouldn't abolish prisons
meaning that physical force can validly
be used to punish criminals then why
should we automatically rule out
corporal punishment which is but one
form of physical Force
well we'll take it one step at a time I
suppose Kyle still needs to figure out
whether laundry detergent companies can
sell their products as a snack I don't
want to overwhelm him with things so we
will let him think about that but for
the time being we will also say that he
is canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]